[Música]
a
[Aplausos]
y mi principal función en esta vida ha
sido el el tema musical
entre otras cosas y va a ser una charla
en la cual también voy a poder
mostrar mis dos lenguajes un lenguaje
que es el que nos enseñan a los humanos
que es el lenguaje hablado y otro
lenguaje que es el que más me gusta que
es el que promuevo pregonó
aplicó también con con mis estudiantes
con personas que quieren hacer
musicoterapia a pacientes y más que es
la música el fenómeno sonoro
y
bueno vamos a empezar el puesto bueno
les voy a contar un secreto antes de
entrar yo dije voy a entrar a tocar como
siempre porque siempre estamos esperando
ante esto yo digo ay no tengo que hablar
entonces me tiene que calmar un poco
para poder
tener en claro está
esta charla y agradezco también a los
otros expositores expositores súper
interesante deberían haber más
encuentros como este para quienes
generar más conocimiento y sobre todo
más crítica en nuestro país y también un
aplauso para los organizadores que creo
que no han dormido mucho pero se han
bancado a este bebé
[Aplausos]
muy bien vamos a empezar
y la música
hay muchas definiciones de música será
la misma música que sonido ustedes que
dicen
no bueno que es cultos de campos
todos los estudiantes de la carrera de
la unsa levanten la mano los estudiantes
así que bien buenas
y
la música tiene sus componentes no
tiene los componentes que son super
fáciles
reconocerlos una parte es el ritmo
aunque podemos escuchar cuerpos
[Música]
ah
en otra parte que es la armonía que será
la armonía adiós rápido
un músico
bueno hay músicos
la armonía es esa parte del camino el
colchón armónico el juego de notas que
nos va a permitir por donde va a caminar
posteriormente la melodía algo así
sonaría una
armonía
[Música]
d
una armonía todo el colchón armónico
por donde vamos a caminar vamos a
navegar en un barco en un tren y la
parte de arriba es la melodía que es lo
que más fácil a veces grabamos no voy a
contar unas cuantas melodías
[Música]
a ver quién conoce esto
en ella
muy bien
quien conoce esta otra melodía a ver
una melodía de un reggaetonero muy
famoso muy famoso
en sus épocas no
[Música]
m
muy bien entonces esa es la melodía la
parte del medio del camino se llama
la parte del se llama ritmo muy bien
entonces una diferencia lo que es el
sonido que puede ser los pajaritos
estamos caminando por las valles de las
ánimas
y otra cosa es la elaboración que hace
un hombre una mujer para crear algo con
una intención esa es la diferencia y el
que quiera discutir pues nos tomamos un
café luego
aquí tenemos un concepto que me gusta
mucho y se es nuestra forma más antigua
de expresión más antigua que el lenguaje
o el arte la música toca a nuestros
sentimientos más profundamente que la
mayoría de las palabras y nos hace
responder con todo nuestro ser
la música está antes que todos ustedes y
que yo que todos
el mundo va girando el universo y la
música el sonido ya está estamos de paso
acá así que hay que aprovechar y además
más
antes que el lenguaje hablado
y más antes que el arte la música es un
proceso muy muy pero muy arcaico desde
los beats que escuchamos de la mamá
cuando estamos en el vientre materno
desde el entorno donde crecemos de esa
manera
vamos constituyendo todo lo que es una
una identidad entonces se va
constituyendo una identidad con todos
estos procedimientos desde el vientre
materno es el piso la identidad sonora
que cada uno cada uno tiene a ver voy a
tocar edito quien se identifica con esto
nadie
muy bien este tema
[Música]
nadie con este
y esperan con este
muy bien
[Música]
sin miedo ese es tu identidad
a quién
sin miedo el proceso de la identidad es
como construimos algo nuestro y creo que
también en bolivia nos falta ser
orgullosos de lo nuestro de dónde vienes
y dijeron con tiempo fui a españa
gustavo de dónde venía y yo les dije
vengo de bolivia un poco sin tímido
porque la mega tímido un poquito me he
soltado por la música y me dicen agotado
y que tocan en bolivia a libia clip ya
me des áfrica digo no
bolivia a colombia
y ya entonces hay que tener esa
seguridad y esfuerzo de decir hombre
vengo de bolivia es mi país y que sabes
tocar de ahí yo no sabía tocar mucho o
casi nada tocaba este tema del
reggaetonero que es la sinfonía del
número 40 de mozart tocaba otros temas y
al final tuve
que buscarme a mí mismo quien soy quien
quiero ser de donde quiero hacer después
y cuando a veces me encuentro con un
boliviano en en nueva york o en parís o
en cualquier parte del mundo o en sorata
le digo oye
cuánto amas a tu país cuánto que haces
por tu país
qué haces y ustedes qué van a hacer y
qué hacen ahora
una pregunta que hay que reflexionar no
que yo me haya planteado y no es
necesario salir del país para imponerte
una camiseta decir al menos a bolivia no
soy paseño amo el gran poder o no sea
amor la pasa en calle no no un
regionalismo no sino una construcción de
quien quiero hacer primero amarme
quererme mantenerlo muy firme sin miedo
y segundo si estamos pisando esta tierra
hay que construir una bolivianidad no yo
la bolivianidad no es nada más que ser
educado amable darle paz a una persona
para que suba el minibús
hacer más personas mundial
son las inquietudes que quería
compartirles porque creo que es una
buena oportunidad para que construyamos
y ustedes ya no son el futuro ustedes
son el presente
cambiamos el dispositivo y en nuestro
país que será pues la música tenemos
tantas culturas indígenas y aprovecho
voy a hacer un
un experimento
mientras el tiempo pasa
y
[Música]
a qué le suena este ritmo
se miedo
o año muy bien
[Música]
o no
y
a mí
[Aplausos]
bien
i
[Aplausos]
t
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
[Música]
en fin
qué
[Aplausos]
ahora
i
por qué
bueno
pasamos
tenemos muy poco tiempo y no quería
dejar pasar siempre mostrar estos dos
lenguajes ya saben el musical que es el
que yo prefiero conversar con ustedes
porque todos somos músicos si algún
profesor les dijo nada tú tienes una
oreja mala hay que discutir y hay que
hacer algo no todos podemos vivir el
fenómeno musical de una manera libre de
una manera espontánea así que hemos
tocado la música hace un momento donde
cada uno se va identificando
nadie se salva del fenómeno sonoro pero
el tema es cómo usarlo cómo podemos usar
en el recorrido de mi carrera
premios y una bendición la música porque
me hecho una persona más diversa
más diversa pensaba que en sucre la
realidad era así de una sola manera no
una ciudad blanca cuando empezó a viajar
a ciudades polícromas hay ciudades raras
hay un underground hay ciudades y
personas y seres muy diversos cuales ha
sido
mi herramienta para entrar a ellas
es un lenguaje es un lenguaje que es
transcultural
donde ninguna cultura es superior a otra
y ayer ha sido también un día bien
reivindicativo a quién sabe
fuerte
no ayer 12 de octubre
anteayer ustedes tan trasnochado a ver
12 de octubre
no es el descubrimiento de américa yo
tengo una posición que es el día de la
resistencia indígena entonces ese es mi
construcción de mi identidad no todo es
bonito no todo es un huayno top que no
hay que además de tocar saber que vas a
decirle al mundo y los digo a ustedes
estudiantes que cuando salgan tienen que
tener un discurso tienen que tener una
ideal una ideología tienen que creer en
algo amar se llaman bolivia trabajen por
ella sino si no la ama pues busquen
otros objetivos esto es súper importante
porque vienen mis alumnos a clases a
aprender jazz o musicoterapia una sesión
y están perdidos dice no sé que me voy a
poner
no sé cómo voy a peinar no sé qué quiero
estudiar lo que quiero hacer
el punto es formar desde muy pequeños
gente autónoma que sepa lo que quiere
apoyar en los potenciales y seguir
construyendo he tenido la oportunidad de
estar en
estudiando la musicoterapia de una
manera empírica y después de una manera
más
formal y
hay un poder que cuando sabemos usarlo
el poder del sonido y poder de la música
nos lleva a espacios muy pero muy
y gratificantes o como uno cuando vamos
supermercado y te ponen un beat y te
dicen compra compra compra compra compra
compra después vas a la iglesia y te
pones
[Música]
no puedo tocar mucho pero nos lleva a un
estado no solamente corporal afecta a
los procesos mentales
al sistema límbico a las emociones o al
corazón y a todo el cuerpo
y si escuchamos
tonterías nada de esto se nutre con una
buena comida
si tienes muy bien tu cuerpo funcionar
pues muchísimo más pero si comes mal
no pasa nada lo mismo pasa con la música
y ahora tenemos que ser muy cuidadosos
con la música pop con la música trap con
todo lo que está ahí lo más fácil que
llega a nuestros oídos lo más fácil es
lo más simple y lo más simple no siempre
es lo mejor para el cerebro perdón para
el corazón por las emociones y para el
cuerpo humano y menos para los niños
para nuestros hijos para nuestras hijas
para saber cómo guiar por qué es tan
importante para mí el sonido de la
música porque con esto trabajo con esto
ayudamos en la musicoterapia a lograr un
bienestar a las personas por otro lado
está el lado performático de lo que es
la música
pasamos
músicos somos todos y eso es súper
importante lo vamos a definir lo vamos a
probar
y bueno
vamos
y así pasado una hora
ops
siga así
todos tenemos que trabajar
[Música]
bien
y vamos
[Música]
mire
[Aplausos]
[Música]
por qué
[Aplausos]
hola
[Música]
i
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
e
[Aplausos]
[Música]
gracias
gracias a las próximas
[Aplausos]